okay let's get into the mailbag for the
week many many many
many emails coming in over the last week
only a few can be chosen remember don't
abuse info davidpakman.com
really if you're emailing every day
we're not seeing your emails they're
getting filtered
right into the trash actually no into a
folder in case law enforcement ever has
a concern about one of our viewers it
does happen
many different topics covered today in
the mail mailbag let's just jump right
in what am i even talking about let's
start with a message from peter
peter said don't underestimate gazpacho
david a number of extremist and
conspiracy researchers have brought up
the idea that marjorie taylor green and
lauren bobert's gaffes and spelling
mistakes are perhaps
deliberate ploys to spread their message
further
it is something to consider as every
time they make one of these mistakes it
goes viral some point you have to wonder
if they're doing it on purpose to get as
many eyes on their underlying message as
possible we already underestimated trump
the buffoon let's not keep making the
same mistake thanks peter yeah i think
it's completely reasonable to wonder
about that i think that there is
no way to argue that these buffoonish
gaffs are actually helping them build
support for any of these things i mean
the the gazpacho thing sure there are
some americans
who have been sort of
tricked or bamboozled into thinking that
there is some kind of vaccine or mask
gazpacho
gestapo but they're i mean they're
people aren't they're not really falling
for that the people who believe that
already believe it i don't think miss uh
pronouncing it as gazpacho is going to
bring people into the movement so i
don't think that they're that clever i
don't think that they're that smart and
even if it's what they're trying to do
to get attention to convince people by
saying gazpacho instead of
gestapo i just don't think it's working
uh at the end of the day and so i'm not
i'm not worried about that
joshua wrote in about bob saget bob
saget the comedian
who died not long ago
we now know the cause of death was some
kind of trauma to his head
uh later went to bed and died
presumably due to some kind of brain
bleed that
became fatal while he was sleeping
joshua said so
now that bob saggett's cause of death
has been released
don't you think it's time for candace
owens to go on tv and apologize for
saying it was due to the coveted vaccine
just a thought
of course
of course candace owens the right-wing
provocateur
said in the days after bob saggett's
death
we got to be looking at the vaccines
here and it's not a conspiracy she said
we just we got to be looking at the
vaccines and of course there was no
evidence that
there was
uh uh
bob saget's death was related to the
covet vaccine and there's no evidence
that some of them say thousands some say
tens of thousands some of them are
saying hundreds of thousands of people
are dying from the covet vaccine there's
no evidence of any of that
but um
someone like candace owens doesn't
apologize and
if if she were
moral and decent she would
but their whole movement i mean listen
trump has never apologized for anything
their whole movement is based on not
apologizing and narcissism
something
very very much uh
present in trump's personality
and i would argue to a great degree with
candace owens as well narcissists don't
apologize
they don't take responsibility it's just
what they do
and we need to we need to understand
that kelly wrote in kelly says
does religion make people susceptible to
bs
hey david hope you're doing well today
i'm a frequent listener couldn't help
but notice the craziest beliefs are
often held by people who will follow
their unhinged views up with a comment
about god or some aspect of religion
you've shown many examples of this on
your show do you think holding religious
or supernatural beliefs leads to people
being susceptible to believing other
non-evidence-based views stolen election
or anti-vaccine let me know your
thoughts
so
the answer is yes and i want to try to
sort of be
like respectful in some sense and i
don't need to make this about religion
let me explain what i mean
we've interviewed on this show
experts in cults
experts in conspiracy theories
experts in conspiracism the psychology
of cults and conspiracies and on and on
and on and they have told us
it is very rare
that someone who is eager
or susceptible to believe
non-empirically based claims like
conspiracy theories
are rarely only susceptible to one
and so the example that's often given is
we often think of flat earth as this
kind of benign
victimless silly little idea the earth
is flat and it's compartmentalized and
that's it but as our experts who we've
interviewed have told us and you can
find a lot of these great interviews on
our youtube channel on our website uh a
lot of the flat earthers also believe in
you know
anti-semitic conspiracy theories that
jews control the world and have
mass population control
uh delusions or you know whatever the
case may be and so
we know that it's true
now it is up to you to decide whether
literal religious beliefs like there was
an ark that had
two of every animal
and they survived a flood that way it's
up to you to decide whether that's an
equivalent claim or um
god
would never
allow
covid to be created so clearly china did
it or whatever belief it's up to you to
decide whether claims like these that
involve religion are the same or not uh
it's not for me to tell you but i think
the trend we see
is that when you are willing to hold or
susceptible to believing one type of
non-evidence-based belief
you're almost certainly susceptible to
holding many of those types of beliefs
and there are such beliefs in religion
that fall under that category
steve wrote in
steve does not like a phrase that i used
he says hello sir
i'm hoping you could either stop using
the phrase put a pin in that or instead
instead say put that in a pin cushion
you don't put a pin in something to take
a break from it you put your pin in a
cushion to come back to it later please
do better says steve from tokyo steve
with peace and love
you're wrong
you're wrong the phrase let's put a pin
in that
to temporarily stop talking about a
subject comes from
putting a pin
back in a grenade
before it explodes
okay now i want to be clear
you know this is like couldn't care less
or
minus well versus i might as well you
know all these phrases that people get
confused uh the the idea here is
you take a grenade and you pull the pin
wow the grenade is now going to go off
you've got to resolve that issue because
the grenade will explode
so when you say let's put a pin in that
what it goes back to is
whoa we don't want this grenade to
explode right now we don't know we need
this grenade you put the pin back in the
grenade
now
many grenades you can't actually do that
but it's
the idea is
we're not actually going to blow this up
now let's put a pin back in it and then
we'll deal with the grenade later that's
the source of it steve and i tell this
to you with total peace and love now is
it possible that this whole let's put
that in a pin cushion i've never heard
that before i'm not saying it doesn't
exist but it sounds like it's a
different phrase different phrase okay
next charles wrote in
and said
i'm running into a lot
of pro-trump propaganda on tick tock and
on instagram reels
yes and i would go further
youtube shorts is a new
vertical video tick tock type format
it is all riddled with right wing
propaganda
we are aware of this we've talked to our
youtube rep about it we've talked
internally
we in 2022 one of the things we're
focused on
is growing our tick tock following
using more of instagram's reels which
are sort of like a tick tock type format
and doing a lot of youtube shorts
because many of you have written to me
and they've said these formats are
dominated by the right so one of the
things we've been doing i'm taking a
look at my phone here
we've been focusing on tick tock where
we are now up to 72 000 followers a
million and a half likes
we're pushing tick tock big because it
is it is a right wing echo chamber in
the political space it's horrible
and you're absolutely right charles
we're going to keep pushing on tick-tock
reels as well as youtube shorts okay
sean wrote in about waning literacy in
the united states sean says mr pakman
sir
the depressing level of literacy on
display in your hate mail
isn't limited to david pakman's show
rage watchers believe me sean i know
sean goes on to say i've seen equally
terrible writing in various corners of
the internet that highlights social
media posts from members of the right
the herman cain award subreddit is an
obvious example but there are many
others i can appreciate that not
everybody is a naturally gifted writer
but in a developed country like the
united states it's scary that so many
adults have such a flimsy grasp of the
english language has it always been this
bad
and we're only now seeing it because
people have more public avenues to share
their written thoughts or are we just
getting stupider my guess is it's a bit
of both either way i only see the
problem getting worse as people continue
to demonize public schooling teachers
science and intellectualism
110
beautiful email from sean i think
there's two things going on i do believe
i don't want to say people are dumber
and in fact by various iq measures it's
not true but
look at
videos
of and this is always sort of fraught
when you do this and i know i'm stepping
into a minefield but
look at videos
of for example
high school and college students asking
questions to the late economist milton
friedman
and you will see
these i'm not going to say the average
student because this is clearly a group
that's interested enough to go listen to
milton friedman the the level of how
articulate
uh these these folks are and how well
spoken they are
compared to what you see
when ben shapiro visits a school and
takes questions it is night and day
so i think there is a change in terms of
how we
sort of expect people to communicate and
grasp on language i think that's a part
of it but the last piece of the email is
also very very true
the right has spent decades now
demonizing public education
laughing off college's liberal
indoctrination and pushing this
anti-intellectualism all for their own
benefit because they know
we're more likely to convince less
educated people to vote for us because
our ideas don't really make any sense
they don't they don't say this but this
is my interpretation of it so there is
an education problem it it's a very
depressing email that does uh
point to some major major issues that we
are dealing with
one other email from linda this is
another one of these phrases
linda says
i could care less is a derivative of i
couldn't care less
the latter is a direct statement the
former is sarcasm as if is implied as an
old person i remember when people
started saying i could care less
it was used only informally and was
considered funny you had to stop to
think and realize they were saying the
opposite of what they meant early on
some people would include the as if as
in as if i could care less i think like
most ironic expressions it was started
by some comedian the humor went stale it
sounds stupid people who use it will
correct it if necessary for non-fluent
speakers of english so they know it's
ironic or say it out of habit
if some young journalist wanted to
research this they could start with
stand-up comedy in the 60s and 70s i had
not heard that if this is true i i
as far as i know
the phrase is i couldn't care less and
when people say i could care less they
just don't understand it linda's saying
there is a historical basis for i could
care less and it was meant in jest to
mean the opposite of what is said
maybe i have not researched it i will
look into it last email today cedric
says dear david
i heard the booster shot enlarges the
prostate in black men
is that true
i am an african-american male
cedric i researched this and found
nothing of the sort
i found nothing that the vaccine
affects prostate size in any man
never mind specifically in black men
check with your doctor if you have any
doubts but i was able to find no such
information
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpakman.com you'll
get instant access to the bonus show
you'll also get commercial-free audio
and video streams of the show available
every day six hours before
the shows are publicly made available
sign up today and you can use the coupon
code wow 22 to get a discount